immigration will be a focus of President
Trump State of the Union address tonight
it comes on the heels of the president's
plan to protect so-called dreamer
immigrants from deportation while
increasing border security it's an
important issue to the five Orlando area
voters we spoke with ahead of mr.
Trump's speech the group range from
liberal to conservative in ideology and
span generations we spoke about the need
for a border wall and the challenges the
president faces overseas Debbie you
voted for Hillary Clinton you're not a
fan of Donald Trump but do you expect
him in this next year to be able to do
something to address some of the issues
you have with his presidency well you
the most forefront issue right now is
daca in terms of immigration he's put a
clock on Congress to figure out you know
a resolution for daca recipients and at
this point Congress isn't coming up with
anything my family my husband is an
immigrant my parents and my siblings are
immigrants they came from Canada and
England respectively if you want to come
to the United States I'm all for it I'm
all for bringing people and because we
are a nation of immigrants but I want
people to come here legally apply for
the resident alien green card or you
know go through the path to citizenship
but the immigration process takes more
than ten years and some people don't
have the luxury of that time some people
are fleeing their countries due to civil
war conflict in their countries my
family's from the Middle East
you know we vote primarily Republican
small-business owners I agree that you
know the laws aren't fair and it takes
way too long to apply to be a citizen in
this country but I don't think saying
the laws are unfair are a good enough
excuse to justify illegal immigration
because that supersedes the people who
are on the wait list and who are trying
to come to this country and do it the
right way Debbie what do you think is on
the president's mind in terms of driving
his presidency what do you think well
right now I do think he's very focused
on the border wall as he has been since
you know he announced his candidacy
personally I think that's a huge mistake
it's gonna be a waste or tax payer
dollars Angela you're a trump supporter
do you care about the border wall and
how much if so I want the wall and I
think Mexico can pay for it when you say
pay for it it does
really have to be monetarily there could
be something of value that could be
utilized from out of Mexico so it could
be a win-win for both of our countries
do you feel safer with Donald Trump as
president absolutely what's your feeling
about North Korea Angela I think North
Korea is is crazy
the man is crazy but he pulls any kind
of stunt he's going to get flattened
what does that mean get flattened we
will retaliate I'd rather be diplomatic
I think North Korea is actually a good
litmus test for how well Trump is doing
because you know he's it's weird but on
the same issue he's at polar opposite
ends because on one hand he's insulting
you know North Korean leader on Twitter
on the other hand you have the South
Korean president who's coming out and
saying you know we give our gratitude
and we're thankful for Donald Trump for
bringing North Korea back to the talking
table so it's just amazing to me how he
can be Trump as crazy like a fox when
I'm very in he scares people who aren't
Americans and don't understand the
nuances of language all they see is a
lunatic crazy man who they can't figure
out and so that keeps them on their
heels I believe Debbie what's your
feeling about the national security
under the trump presidency Angela
mentioned diplomacy I don't think that
President Trump is capable of diplomacy
you know he's insulting world leaders on
Twitter without a second thought
diplomacy is overblown and lookit we've
had diplomatic endeavors to solve the
Mideast crisis for 30 years now I'm
longer than that and nothing has
accomplished just diplomacy as a bunch
of mealy-mouthed people in my opinion
those in the State Department would
differ with that
yeah it's mealy-mouthed bad John I
believe it is that instance its majority
now such those in the state I said those
that are on the front line certainly
hope that diplomacy works before they
get deployed right absolutely or before
it gets to that past they were talking
about with military but you know I love
so much their passion about their
feelings and it shows you when you go to
people and ask them what do you think
they have lots to say and they
articulate it very very well yeah yeah
and it also often doesn't fit right into
the boxes that's right so
it's always good to get out there CBS
News coverage of the State of the Union
begins tonight at 9:00 Eastern 8:00
central Jeff Glor will anchor from
Washington and will be here in studio 57
plus our political team will offer
original reporting and analysis